[Aplausos]
no
[Música]
muy bien así que tenemos una amplia
variedad de personalidades me gusta
mucho lo que veo realmente me están
tendiendo una trampa ahora para ir a
algunas citas a ciegas número uno cómo
te llamas mi nombre es list y es un
placer conocerte soy garrett difusas
esos zapatos a diario o son zapatos de
vestir si son zapatos que usó a diario
normalmente los usaría para trabajar o
salir de noche con mis amigas que tengo
acá sería una noche de fiesta con las
chicas 10 tragos de tequila 10.000
tequila bien a perder el conocimiento si
salgo con ellos está bien yo te cuidaré
o bien música para mis oídos número 2
cómo te llamas clave muy bien eso es un
don que no los de la izquierda son doncs
estos son air force one bien te
consideras una persona a la moda soy más
del tipo de persona de estilo urbano
cómodo bien así que eres activa y pop
no bien concursante número 3 la chica de
los tonos chica tongue cómo te llamas
soy jack y suzy debe ser una chica tipo
lamentablemente
bien entonces cómo consideras que es tu
estilo me interesa mucho el estilo de
vida japonés llamado wabi sabi que
consiste en apreciar lo imperfecto o
esto es hermoso me emociona aprender un
poco más sobre eso número 4 estás
escondiendo tus zapatos eso es por una
buena o mala razón sabes que no
juzguemos a la primera esta no es la
parte principal del atuendo si de dónde
eres y de dónde sacas tu gusto bueno soy
de toronto lo que puede explicar por qué
no he traído los mejores zapatos me
gusta mucho la moda pero los zapatos no
tanto bien eres gran fan de drake no
lo eres bien no sé qué pensar yo soy un
hombre eso es seguro por último tenemos
un buen par de zapatos escondidos allí
sí que te gusta usar zapatos coloridos
en realidad fueron un regalo no los
habría elegido yo misma pero me gustan
mucho entonces te vistes más neutral
cuando se trata de los colores de la
ropa en general me gustan los zapatos
neutros porque siento que los coloridos
o no van con todos atuendos bien bueno
me gusta mucho lo que veo
[Música]
vaya la primera me asusta
los diez tragos de tequila
parece del tipo salvaje pero ella marca
la diferencia sabes muchos de los
zapatos son similares toronto esconde
sus zapatos bueno
hoy
tener que dejar ir a toronto
pero
estás bromeando garrett soy mickey un
placer bueno lo siento mucho tu atuendo
es genial gracias me ves como 195
tú eres el bajito y en lo que pasa se
vuelven contra ti solo así verdad te
dicen todo lo que quieres escuchar en
lago van contra ti está bien me voy nos
vemos pronto nos vemos pronto ojalá mi
corazón está roto en este momento pero
tampoco sé quién más está allí detrás no
puedo pegarme mucho con una
me gusta lo que veo a mucha moda urbana
número uno vaya noté calor as usando eso
estamos en california no sé cómo puedes
así es cómo mantienes tu cuerpo luciendo
genial simplemente sudas todo el día
entonces cuando dices que me cuidarás
qué significa eso bueno te colocaré de
lado para que no vomita sobre ti después
de una noche de copas y te prepararé un
poco de sopa
sopa y me pondrás de lado para vomitar
en el suelo en lugar de la que colocaría
un bote de basura para no tener que
limpiarlo y lo zacarías luego así que
los hago yo por la mañana perfectos y en
la mañana si está bien
pasándola número dos se honesta cuando
llega esta pregunta bien a cuántos
chicos has terminado ignorando
puede que demasiados para cantar
demasiado es para control pero puede que
no te lo haga a ti puede que no me lo
haga para eso es un buen chico hasta
ahora bien me quedo con eso me gusta
todo el tema de la caridad vaya me
interesa bastante ahora
cómo es tu relación con tu papá comido
para soy una niña de papá es mi mejor
amigo una niña de papá y número tres
no esperaba esos pantalones se ven muy
bien me gustan te sientas bien qué tipo
de pantalones son son de pana en
realidad es un overol o entonces una
sola pieza sí porque crees que estás
soltera en este momento realmente no he
conocido al indicado vaya así que estás
buscando al indicado es decir a medida
que envejece es no tienes opción número
4 cuéntame un poco sobre ti qué quieres
que la gente piense cuando vean tu
atuendo siempre digo que me he visto muy
casual quiero verme bien y quiero
sentirme cómoda quiero ser aceptada en
cualquier parte de donde dijiste que
eras de kansas city y la gente en kansas
city suele vestirse así cuando voy a
casa definitivamente recibo algunas
miradas algunas veces con desaprobación
[Música]
hasta el momento por desgracia la número
uno aún me asusté un poco la bebida ella
sabe que voy a vomitar así que estaremos
bebiendo mucho y estoy tratando de
superar eso estoy tratando de hacer lo
correcto por mí mismo
[Música]
hola hola soy lee es un gusto conocerte
soy garrett un placer conocerte lamento
que no podamos ir al club está bien bien
eres muy hermosa y estás muy bien visto
ideas tú eres muy lindo también gracias
y este soy yo fallado de nuevo damas y
caballeros adiós adiós adiós
[Música]
muy bien aquí vamos estoy empezando a
imaginarme más cómo se ven veo un poco
más de sus personalidades bien número
uno cuáles son tus señales de alerta en
los hombres para asegurarme de no caer
en ellas debe ser gracioso yo soy muy
sarcástica y siento que la gente lo toma
como algo muy cruel a veces debes
entender mi humor me harías llorar en
una cita probablemente amo a las mujeres
tóxicas eso es lo mío así que número dos
el overol me encanta sí gracias creo que
se ve genial amo el marrón si pudieras
elegir algo sobre el chico de tus sueños
lo que más te importe que sería y por
qué simplemente que tenga una mente
abierta y esté dispuesto a probar cosas
nuevas qué tipo de cosas crees que
podrías enseñarme comida nueva música
nueva me gusta mucho la comida india en
este momento y también la mediterránea y
etíope
o muy bien la última me encanta el
blazer gracias es como si gritara si
estoy aquí para hacer dinero y para
hacer lo mío parte de mi camino
descubriré me encanta sí claro entonces
cómo sería nuestra primera cita
podríamos comprar comida tailandesa para
llevar y tener un picnic al atardecer
junto al océano podríamos jugar un juego
de cartas o algo así algo muy relajado
pero con mucho tiempo de calidad
concuerdo con eso entonces te consideras
una chica de naturaleza de playa me
consideraría más una chica de montaña si
fuéramos a una caminata me cayera y me
lastimara el tobillo podría llevarme un
lugar seguro o si haría una carga de
bomberos sobre mi hombro una carga de
bombero vaya tenemos una chica un puente
aquí me gusta
pensé que ya no
es tan difícil porque me agradan todas
todas tienen atuendos geniales y ya me
ha repetido dos veces así que no me hace
sentir mejor que puede estropearlo de
nuevo entonces por desgracia la número
dos la del medio será la primera que
dejaría ir hoy
no puedo volver a mirar no puedo volver
a hacerlo no puedo
darle ya que un placer conocerte lamento
mucho haber dejado ir un plus es genial
ojalá nos veamos luego y puedes
enseñarme un poco más de esta comida y
algo de música bien gracias
la última persona a la que dejaré ir
redoble de tambores por favor tienen
alguna batería aquí
desafortunadamente dejaré ir a la chica
número 1
vamos a estar bromeando lo siento mucho
está bien vamos sombreros de pescador
estabas ascendiendo lo allí abajo un
placer conocer y buena suerte en el
futuro y deja de ser tan tóxicas hoy
intentaré
estoy sudando vaya es terrible no quiero
hacerlo más
[Música]
hola soy garrett kaley gusta en conocer
y encantado de conocerte también me
alegra ver que al fin igualmente a
muchos
los que eres como me describo a mí misma
muy casual tu ropa se ve bien en zapatos
limpios te ves único modo y sé que te
sientes cómodo con lo que estás usando
totalmente si esa es la vibra que
buscaba transmitir lo captó
perfectamente ya pensamos en sincronía
así que o intercambiaremos instagram si
de seguro si no doy mi número hasta la
segunda cita es que no quiero que un
montón de chicos sólo tengan un montón
de chicos a motta citas no tantas me
entiendes si sólo vamos a una cita no
quiero que lo tengas bueno no lo sé creo
que la pitcher es bailando supongo que
ya veremos
jubilee vive intensamente